you know right now on on i was reading
vice why was i reading vice i have no
idea
i was reading vice.com and there's a
phenomenon going on on the left it's
called
woke fishing have you heard about this
say have you been woke fished while
dating here's how to tell
there's a gal who's writing serena smith
she says when i was 17 i decided to go
vegan
okay and i mentioned my new veganism to
the guy i was seeing at the time
17 okay and to my surprise he seemed
really annoyed
he responded with an uninterruptible
lecture on the importance of supporting
british farmers
i can still remember one of his appalled
patronizing texts oh no you're not going
to become one of those vegan feminists
are you
i was confused he hadn't come across
like someone who hated vegan feminists
so where had this come from woke fishing
woke fishing put simply is when people
masquerade as holding progressive
political views
to ensnare potential partners a woke
fish may at first present themselves
as a protest attending sex-positive
anti-racist
intersectional feminist who drinks
ethically sourced
oat milk and has read the back catalog
of audre lorde twice but in reality
they don't give an or as is often the
case
they are actively the opposite in their
personal lives it's like catfishing
but specifically with political beliefs
uh
this this is terrific stuff i absolutely
love that even the left is waking up to
this first of all what this woman
doesn't understand
is that every male feminist every male
vegan every male leftist activist is
just doing it to pick up chicks that's
it
the the male feminists they're the
creepiest men on the planet stay away
from them
they're they're pretending to be
effeminate
they're pretending to appeal to you
they're just trying to get you into bed
that's all it is
okay you shouldn't fall for it
that that that's true in the real world
too but this especially seems to be true
on the internet where people can
manicure their own profiles and make
them seem to be something
that they are not well that's what's
going on
we as a as a fact of the internet are
always
we we have much more control in making
ourselves seem to be something
that we are not much harder to do that
in real life though
everyone does that to a certain degree
as well but on the internet they do that
especially it's not just on politics
it's even in your personal life okay
we need to be a little bit wary of that
we need to realize when we talk about
ideology
there's a big difference between the
fantasy of the left and the reality that
we see all around us
big difference between ideological
theories and common sense
the internet magnifies that times a
zillion
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts